and
ketogenic diets done properly can be
great for people the problem is if you
do it wrong you can really mess it up i
tried it once
and i basically got psoriasis i thought
my scalp was going to fall off i was
like sloughing off all this
and i stopped and i was taking the
liquid ketones and then all of a sudden
i felt better again
but i was told that i just did it wrong
yes um that's so i think there's a right
way and a wrong way and you have to
get it right definitely and so i've
experimented quite a bit with keto too
to see how my body feels and doing it
the right way and following all the
instructions
there's definitely a huge difference
that
uh like for example one of the things i
discovered everyone always said this
and but i tried this uh recently over
the past year
is i started drinking when i don't feel
great
if i'm fasting uh bone broth chicken
bone broth oh yeah
and for some reason like magically it
could be this is the other thing the
mind i don't know
but it makes me feel really good oh well
it could be the salt
so i mean neurons the action potential
of neurons as you know is sodium's
rushing into the cell you need enough
extra cellular sodium
in order for your brain and nervous
system to function and so salt i mean
unless people have hypertension salt is
great there was an article in science
magazine about a decade ago about how
salt had been demonized unless people
have hypertension provided you drink
enough water
salt is great you need sodium magnesium
and potassium to function
and for your nerve cells to work i mean
people who over drink water and don't
consume enough electrolytes die
um now hydration is really important i
know david's really into hydration he's
mentioned that a few times i mean
hydrating
properly is key and so you definitely
want to make sure that you're
drinking enough water and getting enough
electrolytes that i mean we should have
actually
talked about that at the beginning
because that's going to keep your
nervous system functioning well
and a lot of people they'll get shaky or
jittery
and when they're fasting and they'll
think they need sugar
yeah and if they just put some salt in
some water they look fine
and like the other stuff from potassium
magnesium whatever the other
electrolytes are but yeah
yeah those three so i mean salt yeah
salty seems good before sleep
um salt i mean this is a vast space and
we're kind of talking about the overlap
between
neurochemicals hormones and nutrition
and it's a fascinating space and it's
one that
the academic community has gems within
the textbooks it hasn't really made it
into the
public sphere yet and i think that's
because people get so caught up in the
you know being are you vegan or are you
carnivore and
there's a vast space in between too that
people can explore like i'm not a
competitive athlete so
i eat meat and i also eat vegetables and
i eat
fruits and it's just about timing them
but i tend to eat carbohydrates when i
want to be sleepy i eat them at night
and everyone said that's the worst thing
you can't do that you sleep great after
eating a big bowl of pasta i'll tell you
you